[Music]
[Applause]
he's a master distiller and you have to
refer to him as that be Master distiller
his name is Brian Nation his real name
and uh he is the Keeper's heart Master
distiller we imported him from Dublin we
spent a lot of time with him and he can
handle his whiskey let's put it that way
let's uh please welcome Brian Nation
[Applause]
yeah there he is the master distiller
bring that microphone a little closer to
you Brian
uh Perfect all right so uh be Master
distiller how long does it take to
become a master distiller long time I've
been involved in the whiskey industry
for uh over 25 years now and I became
Master distiller for the first time in
2013.
um and then did that for seven years and
then decided to opt sticks and move to
the beautiful uh state of Minnesota uh
to make whiskey with Keepers heart okay
but what happened earlier in your career
to get to the point where like what what
what whiskeys are you responsible for or
you had a hand in developing yeah well I
suppose I was I was very fortunate to be
part of a team that developed uh you
know that worked with Jameson Middleton
very rare at a spot range uh powers and
Method Of Madness so fantastic Brands
great Irish whiskey Brands really
fantastic uh Pinnacle of Irish whiskey
so I was very fortunate to work with
them for 23 years and my whole career
really started off as an accident as I
always say it was the best accident that
ever happened to me my background was
chemical in process engineering and last
place I would have thought I'd end up in
was a Distillery worked in a
Pharmaceutical Plant worked in an oil
refinery didn't really enjoy them they
were Grand but they didn't it didn't
kind of give me the excitement that I
was looking for really and then I got an
opportunity to go as an environmental
engineer into into a distillery in
Middleton and cork
and basically work my way up and
ultimately became Master distiller for
fantastic Brands but I've seen grown men
get emotional around when they're around
you
look it's like how famous are you and be
honest now I mean in Dublin how famous
are you
the brands you'd be known by people that
enjoy whiskey yeah so I mean when you
see people that have a love of whiskey
and particularly have a love of Irish
whiskey you're obviously going to be
associated with that so you would be
known
um I got look I just do my job I have
great fun doing it I'm very passionate
about it okay okay hold on
I mean I saw I heard you were calling me
sir Master a while ago yes I mean that
I'm only going by what happened last
night
yeah I said Brian he goes uh it's sir
Master distiller and I go okay then who
takes out the picture of Prince Albert
from Monaco
my God we're gonna go there
because I'm sitting
O'Farrell and you go you got any famous
friends I said well let me text Sandler
Sandler was getting his hair cut right
and I said uh he's getting his hair cut
I said what do you have and then you
pull out the picture with you and and uh
Prince Albert from Monica correct he's a
big whiskey guy he is a big whiskey guy
here could you call him right now no
and the reason I couldn't is I I
wouldn't I wouldn't um I wouldn't expose
him to dislike I mean can you imagine
can you imagine how he'd feel he'd feel
he'd feel wanted
like we're the people do you know what
would happen is I know what would happen
I'd make the call he wouldn't answer and
you just destroy me even more okay
did you bring up Bono last night as well
never met him
was there something I'm only going by
what you told me last night you were you
were in your cups last night and you
started telling me that you knew all of
these famous people right
oh my God
you thought it was just a dinner Brian I
mean
there was a dinner then this is a roast
exactly yeah welcome to America yeah oh
my God yeah it's great funder I'm having
a ball I mean I could never have thought
two years ago that I'd be sitting here
in Dublin under Dan Patrick Show talking
about whiskey
and being with Keepers hats okay explain
to us so let's say you're just getting
into whiskey yeah tell people like this
is what you need to do and not do yeah I
think the first thing is don't be afraid
of it right people have this impression
that that whiskey can only be drunk in a
certain way you know you have to do
certain different things with whiskey
the way I always tell people that want
to try whiskey is try it the way you
know experiment with it you don't always
have to drink your whiskey neat you
don't always have to drink it under
rocks you can drink it in a mixed drink
but the beauty about whiskey is that
there are so many different types of
whiskey out there they really do cater
for all different taste profiles and the
beauty about it is that whiskey is not
just a shooting drink right when you sit
down and you actually assess a whiskey
you take it it takes you on and it
sounds so cliched it takes you on a
journey it takes you on a journey of the
process if the smells of the whiskey
bring back memories of childhood bring
back memories of different things that
happen in your life I wasn't drinking as
a child so you're saying
what is that high in Dublin
um what it does is when did you have
your first whiskey
um I had my first whiskey when I was 19.
oh okay right not and you see you were
trying to go there well you're the one
who said my childhood
but I had my first whiskey when I was 19
but I didn't ever really appreciate what
went into making whiskey until they join
Irish distillers okay we go into this
Whiskey Bar that it's unbelievable
Priceless whiskey fantastic and then you
bring down a bottle and it's got your
name on it
yes right somebody brought down a bottle
okay that had my name okay
I thought you said would somebody bring
down that bottle so I can show it to
people how much did that how much that
bottle goes that absolutely blew me away
it was 75 000 about our 75 000 Euros I
forgot him back in Dublin and 75 000
Euros a bottle and five thousand Euros a
shot
why it's all to do with the Rarity it's
the style of the whiskey there was only
117 bottles of that whiskey made at the
time back in 2014. so it obviously
became a collector's item and then it's
it's supply and demand but originally if
I bought that it would have cost me 150
bucks six thousand Euros that would have
been because it was only 117 bottles
okay okay but it is it's it's a play in
demand and great marketing as well but
when you deliver deliver a cask to
Prince Albert in Monaco
um he's part of our caste society and
with Keepers hatch yeah he's he's uh
he's a a happy member of that how does
he get his whiskey uh we'd send it send
samples
uh sometimes I've been over there you
know it's so what's it like at the
palace there in Monaco
it's fantastic it's it's an unbelievable
experience it's actually like sitting
here really oh yeah it's amazing are you
getting nervous talking about the prince
no it's you make me nervous
yeah because I I've kind of got into
whiskey a little bit later on because I
think it's intimidating for people
because they're not quite like what am I
tasting yeah are you one of those guys
who says oh I can I can taste uh garden
hose tennis ball
a shoe is that are you one of those guys
actually I'll tell you a funny story my
my uh our CEO Mike Duggan uh for for
Keeper's heart basically when I taste
when I taste Keeper's heart Irish plus
American I talk about you know it
reminds me of as a child going into a
sweet shop in my hometown of Cork City
and it was a hard Sweet Shop boiled
sweets and there was lots of different
flavors and I get that with the whiskey
and he's looking at me going yeah right
and but it does it that's when I talk
about the memories it brings it back but
back to your point about whiskey and
being intimidated by it and everything
like that you do hear that a lot and I
do I what I laugh at some people is they
say oh Jesus I could never drink a glass
of whiskey or the last time I had
whiskey oh my God I was sick or I was
this I was there it had nothing to do
with the 25 points they had before
you're kind of going oh yeah you're
blaming it on that one glass of whiskey
and it was it was the other points
before to cause the problem what is it
called when you put the ginger in with
the whiskey or we call that a long drink
so it's a it's a we'll call it a
Keeper's heart and Ginger with a wedge
lime and ice and it's absolutely
beautiful yes it's so refreshing yeah
but we ran out of this whiskey last
night at the bar by popular demo yes we
did do you guys have a question for uh
sir Master distiller Brian Nation Paulie
I guess you know they say I see
sometimes people tasting uh wine and
they swish it around in their mouth if
you are tasting and trying to judge a
new whiskey you're trying should you
just drink it casually or should you
like let it sit in your mouth and go
from there well the first thing you do
with a whiskey is you actually nose the
whiskey yeah and and the reason you're
nosing the whiskey is you're trying to
determine what flavors are you getting
just on the nose
and then when you test the whiskey what
I generally do when I taste the whiskey
is I do leave it rest on my palate for a
period of time I don't swish it around I
think when you leave it's rest on your
palate what you're getting is you're
assessing the mouth feel what kind of
what is it a creamy mold feel is it a
syrupy mold feel and different whiskeys
have different mode fields and then as
that happens the flavors evolve as well
and the pilot and they coat your tongue
and then you begin to get where's the
flavor coming from it's just coming from
the distillate is it coming from the
wood and whiskeys are different every
type of whiskey is different and that's
what makes it so exciting that's why we
I love what I do and you can see I love
what I do and doing something like this
as well is it might be Jesus nerve
wrecking for someone like me but I still
have a lot of fun uh you have a question
uh yeah The Cask Society yes is that
something you sign up for on the website
or Is there a more rigorous screening
process
where for you there could be a bit of a
screening process okay okay but
um no you you can sign up on the website
what we actually do there is because we
are creating whiskey history at Keepers
hack because we're actually making
American Whiskey in the Irish style of
triple copper pack distillation we're
giving people the opportunity to be
involved in in owning a cask of the
first 100 barrels of triple part to
still right triple part is still bourbon
are triple pot distilled American single
partisan so effectively you become part
of the journey and you become part of
the history so it's not just about being
involved with a cask or becoming a
member that can take all of these
bottles of whiskey at the end of the
process it's actually been involved in
the journey and been involved in the
history and we love it people that have
joined it have really enjoyed the whole
trip how many bottles do I get out of a
cask uh if you hold it for about four
years about 240 bottles and then if I
wait longer than that as as whiskey
Waits longer in a barrel it actually
evaporates so you get losses so the
number of bottles will drop down but the
flavors will change change the the
whiskey will evolve and you'll have more
of a wood influence whiskey the longer
you leave it in the bar is there a
chance if I left it in there like a
hundred years that there wouldn't be
anything left I would be buying a cask
that didn't have any whiskey in it
well if you left it here for 100 years
and you're still buying that Cask where
juice did because you're you're you know
you've lasted a lot well no I'm passing
on to my family when I say hey I'm
leaving you this cast and then there's
no whiskey in there Brian I mean sir
Master distiller sir what it actually
would do is you'd always lose the the
problem is that the longer you leave
that and I'm talking if you leave it 50
60 years what could happen is the
strength of the whiskey could actually
drop below what is actually recognized
as a true whiskey which is below 40 or
80 proof uh the most expensive
a glass of whiskey that you've ever had
or most expensive bottle of whiskey is
one that I've ever tasted
um
I tasted actually silent Distillery
chapter one which was a which was a
release from Middleton Distillery back
in I think 20 20 I think
um and that was at the time probably 36
37 000 Euros a bottle so the shot was
you know two thousand two and a half
thousand
but it was beautiful I hope
and I didn't pay for it by the way you
didn't you didn't mix that with anything
right oh yeah I would have been it would
have been a call yeah
I mean that's right
[Music]
sir Master distiller
um thank you again Brian uh every time
I've met you you've uh had this Spirit
but that's who you are and uh you guys
are great Partners we hope this
continues for a long time we hope to see
you in Minneapolis uh thank you again
for uh welcoming us into your family as
well and thank you so much guys we are
having a ball and we are so proud to be
the official whiskey sponsor to Dan
Patrick's also a long mayor continue he
is when you meet him he's uh sir Master
display distiller he's Brian Nation